see the resume on the screen because
we're gonna set everything up perfectly
so you have all the information that you
need
we already know about kd kyrie and james
harden the resume is impeccable like t.i
once said
but before we go here let's check out
kyrie because he's missed the last seven
games due to personal reasons and health
and safety protocol this is the first
time
we heard from him earlier tuesday and he
was transparent and showed
accountability take a listen
i'm a hometown kid so you know things
hit a little different when um
you know family or personal stuff going
on and that's up to me to handle that as
a as a man
um but yeah i just take full
accountability for my absence
with the guys and you know just had a
conversation with each one of them
and we move on it's you know pretty
interesting in watching when you take a
break from everything there's just so
many assumptions
about what's going on and so many people
feel like they know me best
i have no idea who i am or what i'm
about or what i stand for or even
attempt to take the time or even for me
to invite them to take the time so it's
a two-way street
um and when things become overwhelming
in life you know you just got to take a
step back
and realize what's important and i love
to play that's never been questioned
i've committed myself
you know when this wasn't even a thing
for me
you know i didn't really care about
media didn't really care about the
fandom all i cared about
was just the ethics of the game and
being taught the fundamentals
and now that it's become bigger and it's
more of a responsibility that i have in
this position i'm in
i'm grateful because i'm able to stand
on this platform with others alongside
of me that have sacrificed
and are going through similar things so
i'm not alone in this and
um you know that's just a big thing
about
also mental health you know just coming
in and being
balanced with yourself first and then
being able to perform
um so you know with everything going on
the world politically
um socially like i said it's hard to
ignore
um i want to make changes daily you know
there are so many oppressed
communities so many things going on that
are bigger than just a ball going in the
rim
um so for me i just like i said it's
just the balance of it
um of knowing i can delegate my
responsibilities
uh off the court to people that i'm
surrounded around that
are for the fight and are fighting
behind the scenes and in front in the in
the lines and
you know like i said i'm not the only
one that's fighting so i'm grateful to
unify with others and that's all i tried
to do and on the court the same way
just play with a smile leave something
that i've uh
felt very dear to my heart with this
game and then you know whatever my
legacy is after that as a person
that's all i really care about so a lot
to unpack right there kyrie said a whole
bunch but we're in kansas court so
in other big threes we know there's
always a player that has to sacrifice
you think about
dennis robin back in the day with the
bulls maybe you think about james worthy
present day ray allen with the big three
with the celtics chris bosh and so on
and so on
so kyrie now appears to be the third in
pecking order
james harden the primary ball handler
k.d is kd their chemistry is undeniable
candace
is this going to work well ro you bring
up a great point
you talked about other big threes and
with that you talk about
scottie pippen michael jordan and dennis
rodman it is known
which of the big three is the lesser big
three
same thing with miami you talk about
chris bosh dwyane wade lebron james
the pecking order everyone knew who was
going to take the last shot everyone
knew who was going to have to sacrifice
uh d wade being one of the ones that had
a championship lebron going for a
championship chris bosh
coming to join the party so i think that
that pecking order was a lot different
and the same thing
goes with other big threes you even talk
about the spurs in their dynasty with
their big three
um which future which changed in the
future with kawhi being added to that
eventually but in the case of this it is
debatable
kevin durant kyrie irving has won a
championship
james harden is that third piece that's
coming to a team
also uh you take into a into a pack
teams that have drafted players that
haven't traded in terms of big threes so
none of these players have been
with this franchise for an extremely
long time uh katie and kyrie
deciding to come over this summer but
for me
i think success goes off of if three
guys are at their point in their career
when they're ready to win together
because we saw one of the best big
threes that could have ever
possibly been was okc who drafted
russell westbrook drafted uh
uh james harden james harding got him
together kevin durant
so with that being said if they were
25-26 instead of
21-22 would they have won championships
so i'm going to go at
all of these guys are at the stage in
their career
when they're ready to win they're ready
sacrifice and their
men not boys as james harden said now
this this isn't something that's out of
your jurisdiction you've been a part of
big threes in your career as well
you and neca guma kay were the primary
option because there was other players
that had to
in some cases sacrifice as well how did
you handle that situation i think there
is a pecking order but there's also
an ability for everybody to understand
that within whatever game
anybody could rise to the occasion uh as
we've seen just in terms of
with lebron leaning on d wade for
leadership knowing what it's taken
there's a lot of times you don't know
what it takes to win a championship and
guys are striving for that one of the
best players in the game lebron james
did not know what it took
to win a championship until he went to
miami and played with other great
players so
i think james harding is searching for
that searching for that closer which is
kd and kyrie
and i think that they're going to
complement each other i think
everybody's debating they're listening
to all of this and they're understanding
that they have a responsibility
to prove everybody prove us wrong
because nobody believes it's going to
work but guess what
i think it's going to work i got them
winning a championship
i have them winning a championship in
brooklyn i did not say this year
i said within three years the brooklyn
nets
will have a championship and that is the
fact beyond reasonable doubt spitty
i know that you've been a part of some
special teams and all-star in 98 with
the atlanta hawks you had mookie
blaylock and you had to kimbe mutumbo
that was your big three in the atl your
thoughts on this current big three
well you know candice said it best i
know just to add to that
it comes down to communication but it
also comes down to transparent
communication
and also you got to understand is when
you win in a championship
things go on a locker room you're going
to have to be able to be
able to definitely have those
conversations that
you don't want to have and that's what i
think me december mookie had i mean
we had times where we would go after
each other
i mean and it was it was all like
candace said because we all was ready to
win
and we were trying to win i think for
this big three right now is
somebody's gonna have to sacrifice
somebody's got to be more of a
facilitator some people's gonna have to
defend more
but i think more importantly you go also
have to understand is you can't
exclude your other teammates they gotta
feel a part of this
when you want to win a championship
because it's more than just that big
three
and if they can get those guys involved
and not stand around
in constant motion i think they'll be
okay
there it is no objection for candice and
smitty
case closed in candace's court
oh man hold up shouts out to curtis when
did candice parker become the nba
chief justice of the supreme court hey
curtis you ain't know
come on let's go
court candace
court case closed like i said
it's game time all presented by